[Music]
the culmination of ursula k le guin's
fourth earth sea novel hanu
comes with the revelation of who this
child theroux is and that she is in fact
the tahanu
that is named in that very work and the
book begins with her
and ends with her it begins in complete
passivity and ruin she is nearly dead
and it ends with a revelation of who and
what she really is so theru a name that
is given to her by tenar who becomes her
adoptive mother a kargish name that
means burning
is a horribly abused traumatized and
scarred
child who nearly dies after being thrown
into a fire after
her abusers her mother and father and
two other men
have raped her malnourished her beaten
her nearly to death thrown her into a
fire to conceal their crimes she's
brought to
to lark who then gives her to tenar and
she's been terribly maimed her entire
right side of her face is ruined burned
down to the bone the eye gone and the
same with her right hand as well it's
essentially a claw
she is at the same time as she grows
they find a person with power and
nobody's quite sure what to make of this
ojin in dying is going to
use his dying words
to tell
tenar what she needs to do
to teach her to teach theroux
it's not clear what that teaching means
and there's actually a lot of
space devoted to tenor's own thoughts
and
quest to to find ways to teach theroux
but he also says they will fear her
and when tenar
is talking with ivy
a witch about taking tenor on
as an apprentice ivy says i won't do it
and 10ar says well why not and ivy says
i'd be afraid to
and tennis says what are you afraid of a
child an ill-used child and then tenner
thinks maybe it's because of her loss of
virginity she says must apprentice which
be a virgin then and ivy says that's not
what i mean
i mean i don't know what she is
when she looks at me with that one eye
seeing in one blind
i don't know what she sees i see you go
about with her like she was any other
child and i think
what are they what's the strength of
that woman for she's not a fool to hold
a fire by the hand to spin thread with
the whirlwind they say mistress that you
lived as a child yourself with the old
ones the dark ones the ones under foot
and you were queen and servant of those
powers maybe that's why you're not
afraid of this one what power she is i
don't know i don't say but it's beyond
my teaching i know that or beaches or
any other witch or wizard i ever knew
i give you my advice mistress free and
fearless it's this beware beware her the
day she finds her strength that's all so
this is a person of power
saying uh i'm not going to mess with
that myself i don't know how you do it
tenar
the other thing that comes up early on
that we should probably bring up
there is this wonderful story
that tenar
tells to pharaoh as they are climbing
the way to rayalbi to
go see sick ojen they don't realize at
that point that he's dying and she tells
her this is a story that ojin told me
about a woman
who was actually
a dragon
the woman of kameh
you know reveals herself as something
she doesn't say exactly whether she's a
woman putting on dragon's form or a
dragon putting on a woman's form or
something different
and she tells the story of the origin
of both human beings and dragons from
the time that segoi
brought up the islands from the sea
there's other foreshadowing that takes
place in this story before we get to the
final chapter
pharaoh's response
to hearing the word coalescing after
colesian the great dragon the oldest of
the dragons has brought ged
to
um
[Music]
to tenor to be
taken home to be tended
hopefully to see ogin unfortunately ogn
is dead by then
and um
this is this is uh the
three women moss heather and ten are
talking together and then thero is there
as well
and
tenner is trying to say what happened to
her she tried to say the word dragon and
could not her lips and tongue would not
form the word but a word formed itself
with them making itself with her mouth
and breath
collecting she said
theroux was staring at her a wave of
warmth heat seemed to flow from the
child as if she were in fever
she said nothing but moved her lips as
if repeating the name and that fever
heat burned about her
this is a foreshadowing
of what's going on theroux is responding
on a very basic level a bodily level to
this name that somehow she knows
there's also some interesting
speculation about how thero sees the
world we saw ivy talks about that tenor
herself
is going to bring that up as well
and this will
uh
be quite interesting so she's she's
brushing her hair combing her hair
and she asks
here we go thero came to stand
behind her watching tenner
turned and saw her so intent she was
almost trembling what is it birdlet the
fire flying out the child said with fear
or exultation all over the sky
it's just the sparks from my hair tenor
said a little taken aback
therau was smiling and she did not know
if she'd ever seen the child smile
before
thera reached out both her hands the
whole one in the burned as if to touch
and follow the flight of something
around tenor's loose floating hair the
fires all flying out she repeated and
she laughed at that moment tenner asked
herself
how theroux saw her saw the world
and knew she did not know
that she could not know what one saw
with an eye that had been burned away
and ogen's words they will fear her
return to her but she felt no fear of
the child instead she brushed her hair
again vigorously so the sparks would fly
and once again she heard the little
husky laugh
of delight deru
is seeing the world in
a different way through a different eye
you could say
um
a little bit later this is actually in
chapter 12.
there's an interesting uh
discussion the burned and deformed side
of her face was made rigid by the
destruction of muscles and the thickness
of the scar surface but as the scars got
older and his tenor learned by long
usage not to look away from it as
deformity but to see it as face it had
expressions of its own
when thera was frightened the burned and
darkened side
closed in as tenor thought drawing
together hardening when she was excited
or intent
even the blind eye socket seemed to gaze
and the scars read and were hot to touch
now as she went out there was a queer
look to her
as if her face were not human at all an
animal
some strange horny-skinned wild creature
with one bright eye
silent
escaping
so this is uh you know
another prefiguration as well we could
say
and we have uh yet another one in
talking about
wanting to fly now this is in a world
where only birds and dragons fly i
suppose wizards can as well generally
transforming themselves into you know a
bird or a dragon to do so
pharaoh is talking to ged
her face scarred and whole
seeing and blind was intent fiery the
king came in a ship he had a sword he
gave me the bone dolphin his ship was
flying but i was sick because handy
touched me but the king touched me there
and the mark went away she showed her
round thin arm tenor steered she'd
forgotten the mark
someday i want to fly to where he lives
thero told ged he nodded i will do that
she said do you know him so this is
interesting could fly
mean
sail or does fly really mean
fly get is is nodding along it's not
quite clear what what she actually does
mean
we find out what's actually going on in
the
final chapter there's a little bit of
just before the final chapter where we
see that um
theroux turns aside precisely because
she realizes that her mother and father
are going the wrong way
tenor has been bewitched so
here we go
to the left where the roofs of ray all
be slanting down towards the cliff edge
to the right the road that went up to
the manor house this way tenor said no
the child said pointing left to the
village this way tenor repeated and went
off on the right-hand way ged came with
her
and this is where they run into the evil
wizard
aspen of rey alby
theroux has gone off and here we go the
child turned left and went some way
before she looked back letting the
blossoming hedgerow hide her
and now we get to see how she in fact
sees part of the world
the one called aspen whose name was
erissan whom she saw as a forked and
writhing darkness had bound her mother
and father with a thawing through her
tongue and a thong through his heart and
was leading them up toward the place
where he hid the smell of the place was
sickening to her but she followed a
little way to see what he did he led
them in and shut the door behind him it
was a stone door she could not enter
there and now what do we read
she needed to fly but she could not fly
she was not one of the winged ones
so she runs and she goes to auntie
moass's house to find out what's going
on with auntie moss and she finds moss
is indeed very very sick but it's a
sickness brought about by wizardry the
old woman was hiding in her bed she says
he made my flesh rot and shrivel and rot
again but he won't let me die he said
i'd bring you here i tried to die i
tried but he held me he held me living
against my will he won't let me die and
thero says well you shouldn't die
and then she
the old woman says child dearie call me
by my name
hatha the child says now notice that
within the space of two pages this child
knows the true names not only of the
witch who's never repeated it to her
and of aspen who definitely would not
have revealed his true
name to her and then she's
moss says set me free deary and
thiru says i have to wait till they come
til who come deary moss says
my people
who are her people
well we find out
when um here we go
tanner couldn't point couldn't speak but
pointed to the sky above the sea where
this is when they're about to have dead
fall off of the cliff albatross he said
she laughed aloud
in the gulfs of light from the doorway
of the sky the dragon flew fire trailing
behind the coiled male body tenar spoke
then she's able to break the spell
collecting she cried and then turned
seizing ged's arm pulling him down to
the rock as the roar of fire went over
them the rattle of mail on the hiss of
wind and upraised wings the clash of the
talons like sith blades on the rock
the evil
wizard of reyalbe and his followers have
all been destroyed by kalessian the
dragon
get was beside her they were crouched
side by side the sea behind them and the
dragon before them it looked at them
side long from one long yet yellow eye
gad spoke in a horse shaking voice in
the dragon's language tenor understood
the words which were only our thanks
eldest looking at tenor colesian spoke
in the huge voice of a broom of metal
dragged across a gong aro te hanu
the child tanar said theroux she got to
her feet to run to seek her child she
saw her coming down the ledge of rock
between the mountain and the sea towards
the dragon don't run thero she cried but
the child had seen her and was running
running straight to her they clung to
each other
tahanu the dragon said the child looked
turned to look at it kalesin she said
then ged who would remain kneeling stood
up though shakely catching tenor's arm
to steady himself
he laughed now i know who called you
eldest
he's talking to the dragon and then
thiru
says or tahanu says something really
really important
i did
i did not know what else to do
segoy
colessin is segoy this is a massive
revelation in the world of earthsea
coalescing these oldest of dragons
is the one who
created
earth sea itself
so he
coalescing whether male or female or
neither
is not merely a dragon not the oldest of
the dragons but the oldest of
beings
and has named
theroux
to hanu
his daughter
he says to her it was well child i have
sought thee long and then
there says shall we go there now where
the others are on the other wind
and colessian says would you leave these
and there says no can they not come
they cannot come their life is here
i will stay with them she said with a
little catch of breath
calessian turned aside to give that
immense furnace blast of laughter
contempt or delight or anger ha then
looking at the child it is well thou
hast work to do here
i know the child said
i will come back for the colesen said in
time
and to get in tenar
i give you my child as you will give me
yours
in time tenar said
colossians great head bowed very
slightly and the long sword-toothed
mouth curled up at the corner gat and
tenard drew his side with pharaoh as the
dragon turned dragging its armor across
the ledge placing its talent feet
carefully gathering its black haunches
like a cat until it sprang aloft
so they they go on
and get says
her native tongue her mother tongue
to hanu said tenor her name is tahanu
she has been given it by the giver of
names she has been to hanu since the
beginning always she has been to hanu
we know now
what theru
was and is
and we see her
restored
she still remains the scarred child
but now with her identity coming to
everything can be
worked upon can be fixed and there's
more stories yet to come as a result
you